بعد ثلاثة أسابيع في أفغانستان ،
انضممنا إلى الحشود في مطار كابول الآن
الطريقة الوحيدة للخروج من البلاد هناك
كتلة ضخمة هنا الكثير من السيارات
ينتظر مئات الأشخاص في
الحر الشديد على أمل رحلة المغادرة
لذلك تمكنا للتو من الوصول إلى
المطار  مركب
ويجب أن أقول
أنه كان مكثفًا جدًا ، كان
مثل هذا الانجراف من الأشخاص اليائسين
وصراخ الأطفال والنساء والأطفال
،
ونعم ، ليس غالبًا ما ترى
يأسًا
مثل القلة من الناس الذين يفعلون ذلك
مرهقون وخائفون
لكنهم المحظوظون لقد
تجاوزوا نقاط تفتيش طالبان
، حراس الأمن الأفغان وأخيراً بوابة المطار ،
لكنهم لا يستطيعون نسيان أولئك الذين
تركوا وراءهم ،
فنحن سعداء بذلك
ولكننا  حزن على بلدنا
خاصة بالنسبة لأولئك الذين لا يستطيعون الخروج
ممن هم عالقون
هنا ونحن بالفعل حزينون
لأن قلوبنا تنزف عليهم ، ما هو شعورك تجاه
جميع الأمهات اللواتي لديهن بنات صغيرات
سيصبحن الآن.  بسبب حكم طالبان ،
ألم
الجزء الخلفي من طابور طويل جدًا الآن
أه النقل تحت الضغط ،
قالوا ومن الواضح أن الأولوية هي
إخراج الأطفال ، آه والأطفال في أسرع وقت ممكن ،
لكنني أعتقد أننا ربما نكون هنا
لفترة طويلة
هل تعمل  بالنسبة للجيش الأمريكي أو
[الموسيقى]
أثناء إجراء مقابلة مع هذا الزوجين فجأة
صرخوا خلفنا سيارة تسرع من
خلال
[تصفيق]
هذا طفل حديث الولادة
طار لتوه في تلك السيارة
وكان
مولودًا جديدًا هل رأيت أن الطفل
كان بهذا الحجم
[موسيقى
] الطفل الذي اكتشفناه
يعاني من ضربة شمس ويحتاج إلى علاج. تذكير لهذه العائلات
بأنهم قريبون من الأمان ولكننا لم نصل إلى هناك
بعد ،
فنحن نقف في الشمس الحارقة لساعات
ويبحث الجميع عن مأوى يمكنهم
الصبر ينفد
منه إنه بطيء بشكل مؤلم  العملية ولكن
أخيرًا سمح لنا بالداخل
للخارج على مدرج المطار الآن بأمان ولكن الفوضى
مستمرة ،
كنت أنتظر يومين أمس
منذ 3 صباحًا
أمس منذ 3 صباحًا ، نعم
أخبرني ما هو الوضع  كان أيون مثل
محاولة الوصول إلى المطار ، لقد كان
مشغولًا حقًا وكان الكثير من الناس
يقاتلون ويحاولون إفساح المجال
لأنفسهم ،
لكننا دفعنا من خلالنا
بالتأكيد بعض
المحظوظين هنا والبعض الآخر كما سمعت من ذلك
الشاب  لقد انتظرت لمدة يومين ،
أخبرنا الآخرون الذين رأيناهم يتم إرجاعهم أنه ليس لديك
الأوراق المناسبة ولا شك أن
الجميع هنا يبذل قصارى جهده
ولكن ليس من الواضح ما إذا كان سريعًا بما يكفي
إذا كان بإمكان عدد كافٍ من الأشخاص الخروج
وكم  لفترة أطول يتعين عليهم إنهاء هذه
العملية الضخمة